pcsd is raising starting teacher pay as
it works to battle an ongoing educator
shortage sally jaramillo was there for
the announcement and sally what else did
they have to say
brian and denise dr jesus jarrah says
it's a step in the right direction he
also added all of this is due to the
number of vacancies and while he hopes
this will help it's not the only thing
they plan to do
dr jesus jarrah says it's been a rough
time for teachers but he and the
trustees are listening to them the last
time salaries were raised across the
board was 2015 and the district has not
been fully staffed since 1994. they know
they need to make sure teacher and staff
pay is competitive kristin nygro is a
kindergarten teacher at steve short
elementary school now for almost 10
years this is the only district she's
worked for and is excited for what's to
come that's huge right that's a really
big deal for new educators coming in
especially inflation's really our
housing market the whole nine yards and
that really has an effect employees who
are not teachers will get the forty five
hundred dollar retention bonus a five
thousand dollar bonus is for
administrators and police officers a
total of 165 million dollar investment
back out live dr jara also added they
plan on hiring about 30 more police
officers reporting live sally jaramillo
live local now valley thanks for that